oggi i video i miei follower controllano
la mia vita per 24 ore già iniziato con
il primo sondaggio in cui avete votato
di fare colazione fuori e non a casa
quindi siamo ora in giro e ci stiamo
dirigendo là ma l'altro posto che avete
portato quindi durante il video vi farò
vedere i vari sondaggi e farò le cose
che voi avete scelto perché ti fa
trovare ovviamente lasciati un like se
volete vedere un altro i suoi questi
video è dissimile likes farò un altro
tipo di questi video magari con i
sondaggi su instagram visto che molti di
voi non hanno
no volevo dire su youtube visto che
molti di voi non hanno instagram
comunque cercare di timo e niente stiamo
andando
lo re secondo sondaggio era cosa mangio
a colazione la brioche o il rozzo e per
fortuna intanto avete votato il sud
perché volevo mangiare
comunque ora me li faccio vedere è un
dolce tipico spagnolo e sono fritti
beh si immergono nella cioccolata non è
molto estivo lo so però sono buonissimi
l'autore sempre e michele valentina ciao
claudia ciao
lasciate un commento se pensate che si
assomiglino bomba comunque è così che si
mangiano si immerge claudia se la
vittima
e solo lui se venite in spagna
prendetevi assolutamente allora avete
votato che volete vedere il mercato di
malaga e i frutti strani quindi ora
stiamo entrando il mercato non passeremo
nella parte della carne del pesce perché
sapete chi sono cosa italiana
quindi vediamo solo i frutti della
verdura
[Musica]
adesso se la vedrà con frutto questo
stranissimo
anche
sono delle molte vie moses è costato
c'erano questi no
quello è solo brevi
tale scelta si sulle marine tutti i
motori sono piccoli di me
guardate questo
grazie a questo
anche quello lì
ma vuoi devi essere
l'opera non lo bevi ma come detto questo
non so cosa si aprono col coltello lo
bevi
questa invece
anche
strana in quella
molti sono i doriani
caloia
se avessimo segnato
per questo è banale
e però 7 della fiera
allora
vi prego
si ha quindi milano col cucchiaino
forse come vedi il maggiore i fiori a
quelli nell'intima altro fuori solamente
quelli maggiore stimolo sessuale quelli
costruiti rocca 11 del piccante
ora ci stiamo dirigendo come avete
votato via chiesta se preferivate fare
shopping dai se ne fa shopping con me
per il genere moda bershka e avete
votato bershka io penso che in tanti
votate insieme mio propri pete best e
poi avete votato anche che volete che
faccia shopping a primark quindi
stiamo andando verso il centro
commerciale
insomma staremo insieme a fare un po di
shopping la bestia primark forse anche
qualche altro negozio che metterò poi in
fondo oggi e vediamo conta compreremo
una cosa così
io
dopo la libia
primark nel caos di trademark vediamo se
troviamo qualcosa si intende che teheran
di per sé glitter che bei colori la
carica di 101
la sea ray
a
[Musica]
e bello
quest'anno le bolle giganti
[Musica]
ceccarini
no
ora
ai minori
ecco
[Musica]
chi è
vediamo un po se ci sono nuove borse
interessante questo tipo limitazione
gucci
l'ostacolo
uguale
[Musica]
che carina questa
buongiorno si sono bianco di mimì questo
di topolino il massimo per fiocchetto
ecco un'altra mini questa donna però mi
piace questo cappello da mare
asciugamani guardate qua c'è la lampada
del genio della lampada è in realtà è
una teiera questa fighissima però già
quella di della bella e la bestia quindi
non so se essere questa
bene se questo è l'asciugamano pinza
tondo fantastico
guardate qua sapete che sono una fan di
mimun e ciò anche a pupazzo via dietro
bucari anche la collina poi abbiamo la
tazza di buzz lightyear di toy story
piccoli
ma le cose di harry potter c'è questa
trovata giuro solennemente di non avere
buone intenzioni qualcosa di scontato e
poi sono questi nuovi
guardate piccari allora scopriamo questo
errore
poi c'è questa nuova tassa grifondoro
nuovi cuscini delle case un po più
piccoli oddio questo che ha un
salvadanaio si becca
carino questo come prima
[Applauso]
mi piace questa stella
funziona merate carini queste le fantini
problemi
[Musica]
buone san vittorino
l'uncem ancora foto l'ha attaccata la
faccia velocemente vedere quello che ho
preso che avete scelto voi velocemente
perché poi usciamo nuovamente a cena
questa sarà una festa più tardi insomma
poi vedrete comunque vedere perché avete
sentito con voi
andiamo con una ford allora in sé stesso
da travica rischio chiesti se volevate
che prendessi di top nero o rosa
e voi avete sempre 51 per cento ha vinto
il man
in realtà però anche l'inchiesta ruota
perché un colore che non ho molto
nell'armadio però ha visto è vero
comunque di pochissimo e me lo faccio
subito bene eccolo qua questo è il topo
nero è un pronto quindi rimane un po
corto mi piace tantissimo come sta
addosso e lo stesso che indossavo primo
per oggi colore marrone quindi l'ho
potuto prendere anche di un altro colore
perché è bellissimo e seconda forza
sempre da straripare studio chiesto se
volevate che comprarsi d'eze pezzi o no
e per il 74 per cento ha vinto i sì mesi
6 per cento no quindi diamo prendere le
possibile eccole qua ha detto non
esempio vorremmo appunto un paese di
sette perché sono più comode sono datate
ma sono anche più comodo dei tap in toma
e per l'estate
eccole qua fatemi sapere se il piano non
sono altissime gli ho chiesto se
volevate che prendete un cassetto
l'unicorno o il gatto e io mi aspettavo
che in tanti ha preso e portato qui
ricordo perché so che adorate tutti gli
unicorni quindi per un 89 per cento ha
vinto l'unicorno è ora te lo faccio
vedere carinissimo super calino fa il
corno gianluca la colina e super tenero
e questo lo metto carmelo studio
scrivetemi pure i commenti come vorrei
che ti chiami questo unicorno egli
assegnerò il nome più votato quindi
lasciate laica un nome che vi piace ora
l'unica cosa in cui non ho seguito il
sondaggio è stata di questo completo in
tantissimi ma non si sa per cento mi ha
detto di prenderlo è in realtà un po
attardato in questo completo nel senso
inserire io non
vesto così soprattutto i pantaloni più
che altro non mi convince valore di
shopper che rimanevano molto larghi
vedete un po sulle gambe e nonostante
poi il primo momento per cento
avete votato di sì sinceramente non mi
ci vedevo un proprio anche se il mio
amico mi chiamo al caduta va molto bene
ma non lo so mi sentivo troppo strada
del pontano di posizionare che il naso
perché ma gruppi di potere alternatore
dei pantaloni alla fantozzi tipo perché
sono lunghissimi qua e voi larghi quindi
insomma non mi sentivo molto a mio agio
quindi ho deciso anche siamo già messo
il sondaggio deciso poi di non preme poi
un'altra cosa che vi ho chiesto se
volevate che prendessi e da primark la
maschera per dormire comunque per
coprirsi gli occhi unicorno che appena
l'ho vista ho detto oh mio bellissimo
era avete votato 88 per cento di sì
ovviamente erano la fazione eccola qua è
carinissima e il corno e glitterato
brilla è troppo bella e costava al 2
euro e 50 su per muovere anche le
orecchiette e tre molto carine poi gli
ho chiesto se volevate che comprarsi il
cappello da mareco
bombe ma per esiste il giorno presente
di mettere di nuovo ot rapito per quel
cappello o mista vasto per male o non mi
piaceva per niente fatemi sapere nei
commenti perché non ho visto mai una
percentuale così alta
no non l'ho presto poi gli ho chiesto se
volevate che prendessi quest'altro
sempre da mare però un po più classico
elegante essere il 71 per cento mm3
turisti e all'approvazione
eccolo qua lo prete appunto sempre da
primark portava 4 euro ed è fantastico
per il mare fa tutto e trucco ma a un
fiocchetto qua davanti è presissimo
cappello da mare
mi piace molto fatemi sapere come mista
se sembro tipo che si chiamano quel
cartone dicono che pescava sampei se
sembra fame o se vista bene prossima
cosa ho visto sempre dal re marche
cucine di mini ep e se volevate che lo
prendesse un no e il 77 per cento viene
tutti prendo quindi eccolo qua sono
fatta bellissima che mi avete eletto di
prenderlo
che sapete che mi lu mi piace tantissimo
e camera o il pupazzone gigante anche
altre cose che mi hanno fatto vedere che
un prezzo assai marketing ed eccolo qua
mi piace di più è che c'è il tubetto di
menu con il più credito troppo carino e
poi girato dall'altra parte a sezione
teseu strisce rosa questo metro in
camere si abbinerà alto tutto il resto
di cose però perché poi ultima cosa
per quanto il coro lo shopping che vi ho
chiesto era se prendere questa donna
pantani keynote abder scalper che
vediamo appunto chiese alimentatore
volte che i nostri proposta è presentato
sette presente mi avete le 13 quindi ora
me la faccio vedere
eccola qua allora perché perfetto con la
patologia perché davanti sembra una
donna coi bottoni ma in realtà dietro e
si vede che un pantaloncino di ciò
perché è un pantaloncino io in genere a
mente del prezzo piu le donne però
comunque è comoda come control 5 sono
contenta che avete votato di sì quindi
questo era lo shopping e ora andiamo
insieme a cena vediamo insieme a una
festa in spiaggia più che pronti
andiamo ciao femme allora avete portato
via chiesto sempre se rivolte che
andassimo in pizzeria o ristorante arabo
e avete votato pizzeria quindi ora sono
né pizzeria e dopo ci sarà una stessa in
spiaggia quindi film ero un po è vero
che si vedono anche se sarà sotto buio
vediamo
vedremo insieme quindi ora andiamo in
serie la pizzeria napoletana
spero non ci sia troppa gente ora
vediamo poi se siete napoletani mi
farete sapere nei commenti se davvero
pizza napoletana
[Musica]
lucca i ragazzi questa è la pizza fatti
di sapere cosa ne pensate
[Musica]
se tu
[Applauso]
se non lo vedo
[Musica]